in this video I want to talk about fatty
acids and just a brief introduction to
them so fatty acids are usually found as
part of try acyl glycerols
triacylglycerols are also called
triglycerides which are also called fats
and the reason why fatty acids are part
of triacylglycerols is they're primarily
used for energy storage in many
organisms fatty acids the reason why
they can store energy is because they
are highly highly reduced molecules what
does that mean well if something has
been reduced its carrying a lot of
electrons so something that's highly
reduced means it has lots of electrons
which is not lost lots of electrons lots
of electrons means lots of potential
energy which we can use to make ATP in
the electron transport chain
we'll get to that in just a second this
is something that we mentioned this
whole idea of potential energy with
electrons it's something we mentioned we
talked about nadh is and fadh2 is being
electron carriers so as a matter of fact
these fatty acids the fact that they are
highly reduced when they're broken down
that results in the production of lots
of nadh and fadh2 we'll get to that
shortly but basically if we care to
create a lot of nadh or fadh2 s we can
reoxidized them and create lots of
energy lots of ATP so now quick fun fact
if you think about the amount of energy
you would get from a car versus fatty
acids for carbs you would get 4
kilocalories per gram of a carbohydrate
that's how much energy you would get
from one gram this is sometimes an
important piece of information for
nutritionists for fatty acids or for
fats you would get 9 kilocalories per
gram so they are fats are a much more
efficient way to store energy so let's
think about this just to give you a kind
of idea what's going on here if we have
if we have a an 18 carbon fatty acid the
amount of ATP you could get out of an 18
carbon fatty acid you could net 120 a
cheapie and we'll actually see that in a
future video exactly how we get this
number
what if we had 18 carbon you know a
carbohydrate like glucose well we know
glucose is a six carbon molecule so if
we had three glucoses right that would
be 18 carbons right so because 3 times 6
of course is 18 so 18 carbons worth of
carbs versus 18 carbons worth of fat so
if we had 8 and 18 carbon fatty acid we
would break that down for 120 ATP how
much would we get from 18 carbons worth
of glucose right 3 lucullus molecules
well we get 3 times the amount we get
from one glucose right which is
somewhere between 32 32 ATP so that is
that at most right it would at most 96
ATP right that would be on most of
course you can get 3 times 30 which is
90 or somewhere in between that but the
most you would get is 96 which is still
less than you would get from a fatty
acid so essentially the idea here is
that fatty acids are an efficient way to
store energy now how do we actually get
fatty acids well we mentioned just above
just hear about these trays of glycerol
these triglycerides
so if we have fats right
triacylglycerols triglycerides they look
like this if you recall this portion
here in white is the glycerol backbone
and each one of these here is a fatty
acid that was attached to it if we have
trays with withdrawals we can hydrolyze
these bonds and free up fatty acids this
is this here that I've drawn here this
is a free fatty acid so if we want to
free up these fatty acids arm from a
trace of withdrawal or a triglyceride we
would have to add a particular enzyme
and those kinds of enzymes are called
lipases on the flip side these fatty
acids are also parts of phospholipids
right phospholipids are a little bit
different than triacylglycerols instead
of having a glycerol and
and three fatty acids phospholipids have
a glycerol backbone two fatty acids and
some sort of phosphate group on on it as
well
so this is specifically I've drawn
phosphatidylcholine that's not really
too important the point is that it's a
phospholipid and we could also you know
hydrolyze these fatty acids off the
enzymes that we use to break these off
our phospho lipases so why am i bringing
this up I'm bringing this up because
we're going to talk about fatty acids
and how to actually break them down for
energy before we can even do that right
we need to free them up themselves you
need to have fatty acids so hopefully
that was a quick introduction thank you
for watching